all right america's got talent winner
darcy lynn is bringing her ventriloquism
to the mirage it's been five years since
she wowed america and the judges and she
continues to keep the craft of
ventriloquist
alive for the next generation jillian
had the chance to talk to darcy lynn
ahead of tonight's show check it out
well darcy i'm so excited to chat with
you a youngest contestant to ever win
america's got talent millions of views
on social media you're killing it on
tick tock but let's go back because we
all remember that young little darcy and
now you're so grown up how has it been
growing up in the public eye we've all
been along on this journey with you
oh my goodness it has just been
whirlwind of five years i i won when i
was 12 i'm now 17 which is just
blows my mind i have gotten to do so
many things i never would have imagined
i get to do and i never would have
imagined ventriloquism would be the
thing
to take me here but it's been amazing
i've been touring
um and
i'm just living life i'm gonna be a
senior next year trying to figure out
what i want to do after high school
so all these and all these amazing
exciting things are happening now and
it's been amazing
yeah a lot of exciting things ahead for
you and we are looking forward to having
you out here in vegas as part of one of
your tour stops so let's talk about this
tour what can people expect when they
come to see your show
yeah well my show is super
multi-generational and you know when i
go to my shows we see like kids from
three and then all the way up to 83 it's
the best i love my crowds and it's a
variety show and
um we have like so many different genres
with music that i'll sing a live band
that plays all my music i'll have all
five of my puppets there with me
including the newest one and all new
comedy um and it's just all new songs so
it's everything's new um to last year
and i'm super excited to bring it to
vegas this is so exciting darcy lynn is
performing at the mirage tonight at 7
30. she's so cute